when you think about uh your career in
buildings a lot of young people who
watch this uh what are some of the
things that you learned early on that
you're like wow if i had known that even
earlier or things that maybe you know
now that you're like if i if i had
learned that stuff earlier in my career
i could have leveraged that whether it
was uh if you had been inside of a
corporation building your own business
uh or just kind of doing transactions
etc what are some of those lessons
learned
you know i've been reflecting on that a
lot lately because
one of the things i've been doing is
funding a lot of businesses with
entrepreneurs kind of like what you do
and uh you know
it sounds crazy but i would just say you
know do the work do the work uh you know
so many people try to look for the short
the shortcut or the quick work or
whatever i'll give you an example i just
invested in an air conditioning business
and the guy who runs it he's below 30 i
don't want to say exactly who he is and
he keeps looking and he's watching all
these different podcasts and everything
and his real talent is selling air
conditioning and i just said to him i
said stop watching all these podcasts
stop reading all these books just go
sell the units door-to-door and you know
he doesn't want to hear that but so i
would just say do the work you know
watch pomp show
learn what you can here learn what you
can other places but you just got to do
the work and i think that with this
liquidity that's in the market right now
if you do the work
there are so many options to get paid
for it right now i mean it's just
ridiculous i mean can you believe that
they're selling us they're allowing us
to buy bitcoin at these prices right now
so you know go sell some air
conditioning units or go sell you know
whatever right and you know stacks ads
how important do you think it is for
young people to learn like what i call
like the basics of business so
accounting selling um you know uh kind
of strategy operations like those key
components versus hey i already know
that i have an inclination to be good at
sales i already know if you're good at
it you should lean into it i think and
hire the best people around you right at
least that's how i've done it and
everybody i know who's been successful
right i mean even you you've hired
people who you know round out your skill
set so
so yeah just kind of lean into exactly
what lean into what you do don't run
away from it people try to do it now i
do think that there are some basic
things right that you can learn for
example i think one of the things that
you know good entrepreneurs good young
people can learn is finance because
finance to me is the language of of
business and so um you know a lot of
people give a lot of different advice
you know i'm trying to avoid giving
advice and just saying hey do the work
and if you are going to learn you know
some type of skill set to augment it
finance because uh so often i run into
these businesses i'm sure you do too i
think
sometimes you're you're investing with
people maybe you have more finance
background a lot of people i'm dealing
with don't have a finance background and
they don't really know how much money
they're taking home at the end of the
day and and the inability to know how
much money you're netting after you pay
the government um you know a lot of
people don't realize they they have a
business partner and even if they don't
have a business partner and that is the
federal government because they have to
pay 40 of their taxes and so i think
really understanding finance can really
help you become a wealthy you know
wealthy individual because if you if you
know your core skill set you hit it home
you hire around it and then you you
really understand finance to know how
much you're netting and putting in the
bank you know one day you'll wake up and
you'll be wealthy and you got to have
you got to have ten dollars before you
have a hundred dollars you got to have
hundred dollars before you have a
thousand dollars right so you gotta have
a million dollars before you have 10
million and that was my experience too
it feels like um there's a uh
a key component to
um
the way you talk about it i talk to
founders all the time and they'll always
say uh hey you know i make uh i make 10
million dollars in my business and they
talk about top line reference correct
right and then you say okay well what do
you do after expenses and then they'll
give you a number exactly and then
you're like okay now what after that
like you gotta like literally walk
through it and that's what your point is
that 10 million actually end up maybe
two million yeah right i say revenue is
vanity and profitability is sanity ah i
like that uh my grandfather taught it to
me and um
yeah it was just a great one because
everybody they go around to these
industry trade shows at least in our
industry beat their chest oh look at how
big my revenue is and then you know it's
like okay dude but show me your bank
account how much did you take home at
the end of the day you know what what do
you think are uh some of the key things
that you did in your life from like a
finance standpoint in terms of uh not
maybe not understanding what to do but
uh
like good habits that you have that
you're like okay if it doesn't matter if
you make a gazillion dollars a year or
you make one dollar a year if you have
these types of habits like i think that
really puts you on the right path i
would say you know how i made my first
let's say a million or two million
dollars which was really really
important to me uh because that really
gave me the confidence to to go forward
was that i bought businesses uh where i
bought into things that had cash flows
and what i mean by that is i bought
positive cash flowing things a lot of
people like to buy negative cash flow
and i know you like to start you know
small and incubate and
lose money
that's true is if you focus on uh
positive cash flow entities you can make
your life a lot easier in my opinion and
what happens is you get compounding
working for you you get the
it's almost like a law of nature
compounding it can work for you or
against you and so i would just say you
know be a little bit patient now it took
me several years to make my first
million or two but then once i figured
that out and i got the law of
compounding working for me it just went
like straight up like a hockey stick so
you know again this is unsexy advice
right but uh yeah but it works yeah it
works buy cash by positive cash flowing
thanks could be anything could be an
apartment could be a reit could be a
business could be whatever and just let
it sit there and cash day after day
after day because if you look at the
bank account day after day after day you
say wow i'm not making that much money
but then when you start looking at it
you know after 30 days 60 days 120 days
right this stuff starts to pile up and
over a period of years you know you'll
wake up in three or five years and
you'll be worth a shitload of money and
then sorry i don't know if i can swear
you could say whatever you want and then
it's the internet yeah i know but like
jimmy's channel you can't
say anything bad on it because i don't
know um but i forget what i was saying
but so anyway so if you just compounded
over time you know uh
you know i think that if i had to start
all over again that's what i'd do yeah
uh one of the things that we talk about
a lot is uh how this weekend somebody
can go out and make a thousand bucks
right so just like uh all these ideas
and one time joe uh which is crazy
because i think when we graduated from
college i don't know i mean it
thousand dollars was a lot that was i
mean it was right so
yeah i mean a thousand dollars still a
lot yeah i say one dollars a lot but
yeah it's it's a lot but but the amount
of purchasing power for a thousand
dollars today even versus you know
2005 2010 like anywhere in that time
frame uh you know look at the inflation
level right we've literally just in the
last year 38 of all dollars during the
last 18 months have been uh printed
inflation the official numbers are up
over five percent so i mean it's it's
pretty crazy how much uh purchasing
power's been lost but one of the things
that uh we we talked about was jokes it
was basically like hey if i want to make
a thousand dollars what i would do is i
should go to local country club and i
would caddy basically i'd go surround
myself with rich people right and in
some weird way like some money would
fall out of their pockets into mine
right i think too like the the
difference too is like are you looking
to build something sustainable that can
grow and scale and make more money and
become something with enterprise value
or whatever right like that's one
scenario but if you tell me you have
until the end of the weekend to make a
thousand dollars like what's the most
high upside thing i can think of that's
probably manual labor that you actually
have to go outside and go do something
for it's probably the country club right
you go to a golf course and you caddy
for some people and you try to find your
way to get some cash other than that
it's going to be hard to start something
within 24 or 48 hours online and build
something yeah but even then like let's
say you put away the thousand dollars
let's say you put in bitcoin or
something else over time that will
compound to be significant and you know
i think a lot of people could look at
you pump and think oh well you know
pomp's so successful and you know he's
investing in all these businesses and
everything but you're kind of an outlier
in a sense that you know
you have access to deals that very few
people have and whatnot so somebody
might be watching this and they might
not have the access to the vc channels
for example that you have
excuse me and so it's a horrible idea to
angel invest if you're basically sitting
pretty much anywhere in the world other
than uh you don't have to physically be
in these geographies anymore but you
have to be in the networks and if you
know i just go out on the street and i
just ask people like hey what's in a
business i want to invest
i'm going to lose money for sure exactly
right because it's just you let's say
let's do that reverse so let's say you
go out to the street and you say hey put
your thousand dollars in this reit i
don't know making up some you know
some some reit i mean
yeah they could depreciate it but are
they going to lose money doing that
probably not right yeah well the reits
and then also you could even do it for
not all businesses but a lot of the s p
500 you know oh yeah well you can even
go back
you know go by the queues you can even
go and uh and invest in local businesses
right we had somebody come on uh cody
sanchez who basically talked all about
like uh one of the businesses that she
bought into was she went to somebody
they owned a like a mailbox business
which was uh kind of like if you ever go
to the post office they have like po
boxes similar type of business but it
was the local mom and pop one and uh she
went to them and said hey i love your
business uh i think that maybe you need
help you know either marketing or kind
of getting the word out uh but i'd like
to buy into the business and so she gave
them you know
not a small amount of money but but also
not millions of dollars i don't know
what the 50 hundred thousand dollars
whatever it was uh and she bought like i
think it was
maybe a third of the business and the
business was doing you know 250 000 in
uh cash flow yeah right and she's like
wait a minute i just bought
like this is like a no-brainer type deal
yeah and so you don't necessarily have
to go and invest in the next in the next
facebook to be able to make money right
it's the reason why there is so much
asymmetry in early stage technology is
because there's so much risk
right like you you basically are getting
paid for the risk that you're taking i
think people forget that point about it
right is they always want to say oh i
can make a bunch of money everyone
always looks at the upside
but the downside is zero
versus a reit or something like that
that you know again sure on a very very
outlier case that could happen but the s
p 500 is not going to zero exactly right
and so the risk is very different so you
should expect if you can get a 30 return
in the s p 500 and have you know what's
the downside uh
maybe it goes down 30 and the government
steps in and you know pumps equity in
the market like it did in may of last
year or march last year okay like that's
a pretty good trade-off exactly and then
if you look over a long period of time
like the stock market is not allowed to
go down right you know like it has not
it's not that instant gratification you
can look at it every day and say oh wow
look at how much money i made or
whatever i mean maybe buy something with
more volatility like bitcoin but the spy
over time you know you make money the
damn thing just keeps going it's the
classic saying uh time in the market not
timing the market compounding if you if
you don't know anything about investing
compound compounding is the greatest
thing in the world you know john has got
some fire one-liners today
what'd you say earlier uh uh many hands
many hands make light work yeah which is
very true when i was like 21 i
asked mitt romney it was kind of weird
uh and i don't know well at all but i
asked him i said you know what what's
the key to your success at bain capital
and he said
my key is i buy something for the right
price and i have a spinning ball effect
and to me
the spinning ball was always that
compound interest so at bain i guess you
know this is what he was arguing to me
and it's just always stuck with me since
i was like 21 right and so i don't know
i just i just try to like literally
other than give away my money on twitter
which
frankly i like to use the compounding to
fund what i'm doing on twitter but um
you know that's what i try to do every
day you know buy stuff that's low
that's spitting out cash and then just
have that spinning ball effect yeah it i
mean it's a no-brainer this was not to
say oh i talked to mitt romney once no
it's not
i'm not into that what i'm saying is
this guy built a really good business i
was 21 years old it was it was a very
impactful conversation to me so do you
mind talking about your personal
portfolio a little bit like what uh what
not necessarily financial advice but
what you see as opportunities and what
you kind of like sure so i own a lot of
the qqq so the technology etf i own a
lot of the spy and then i own a lot of
bitcoin
so
so yeah i own a lot of bitcoin i mean i
mean not as much as i probably should
but it's a lot so and
what is the reason behind
bitcoin and the qqq
well the queues are getting beat up this
week because the interest rates a little
bit but um
my thought is that the queues are
businesses that are almost like
monopolies they're almost like cartels
it's sad to say but they are and so to
my point earlier about buying the
spinning ball effect i mean
google is a spinning ball it's going
down the street and it's generating i
mean what did did you guys hear this
that google's revenue is like 30 growth
rate i mean this is insane after it's
been growing as fast as it is and now
it's growing another 30 percent and it's
ebitda margins i don't know if you guys
have seen this but the ebitda margin is
like 30 35 i mean these things
i mean they should be broken up right uh
but they're like cartels so i say to
people especially people not at means i
say you know again this is not
investment advice but i say you know go
buy the cartels go buy go buy the
monopolies like if that's the game we
have to play if that's how it's been
rigged
buy the monopolies buy those
buy those big companies so i i hold a
lot of equity risk i don't view it as a
risk and it is risk but uh do you hold
bonds i don't yeah i feel like that's
probably the biggest thing no gold
hey guys bang bang thanks so much for
watching the best business show today
and don't forget to check out our
partner sofi they make all this possible
they're a super app that lets you save
spend borrow earn and invest all from
one single platform and if you go there
today and you sign up for a sofi invest
account you can get between five dollars
and a thousand bucks for free from sofa
not everyone's obviously gonna get a
thousand dollars but everyone gets
something don't say that i never did
anything for you go check them out at
sofi.com
download the app and go ahead and open
an account sofi.com pomp and make sure
you come back and watch more of the best
business show we're going to build the
biggest business show in the world and
we need your help
[Music]